بعد شكري المانيا والولايات المتحده على
قرارهما ارسال دبابات ثقيله لاوكرانيا
فريد ميرسينيسكي يطالب بالمزيد رئيس
الاوكراني يقولوا ان بلاده بحاجه الى
صواريخ بعيده المدى وطائرات المقاتله
السرعه والكميه في تسليم الاسلحه هي
المفتاح لدحر القوات الروسيه يضيف زينسكي
ولم تتاخر روسيا الى تحذير من ان تزويد
كيف بدبابه ثقيله خطوه خطيره جدا تمثل
استفزازا صارخا اخر ضد موسكو
ومعنى الان من موسكو مراسلنا مازن عباس
مازن اهلا بك اذا تقول ان الدبابات التي
سترسل الى اوكرانيا ستحترق مثل ما احترقت
سابقتها محضره اذا من تصعيد مقبل على
الجبهه ما مظاهر الاستعدادات الروسيه
للمواجهه المقبله في اوكرانيا
هي مهام ضمن الخطه التي وضعت بعد تغيير
القياده العسكريه اااه هذه المظاهر تتمثل
في تكفيف في عمليات القصف على المواقع
التي تقع ضمن الاقاليم الاربعه التي انضمت
الى السياده الروسيه واا تقدم القوات
البريه باتجاه باخ موت وايضا باتجاه همم
مدن اخرى في محاوله لفرض السيطره عليها
هذا هذه ال- ال- الخطوات هذه الهجمات هي
عمليا على مدار الايام الماضيه كانت تتصدر
الاهداف والمهام الروسيه وبالتالي هناك
همم مساعي من قبل موسكو لفرد سيطرتها على
كافه اراضي الاقاليم الاربعه التي انضمت
الى السياده الروسيه نصف قطر ان تحقيق هذا
الامر ي الانتصار لها باعتبار انها فرضت
ارادتها على تحالف غربي كبير ضمه كافه
الدول الناتو ربما ضم ايضا دول من خارج
حلف من خارج حلوفه من اليوتيوب همم
لكن في هذه النقطه يقال في الدول الغربيه
بعض المحللين يقال يقولون ان التفاه
الاتفاق همم اتفاق بين الالمانيه
والولايات المتحده مع حلفائهم الاوروبيين
على ارسال هذه الدبابات يظهر ربما فشل
سياسه بوتين الذي كان يعول على انقسام بين
الدول الغربيه هل ينظر للامر كذلك بين بعض
المحللين الروس
مجموعه من المحللين الذين منذ البدايه كان
يرون ان العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
ستدور بروسيا يعتقد بان الوضع مات خطيره
وان التوتر يتصاعد وان هذا التحالف الغربي
ضد روسيا لا شك انه يهدد همم الاقتصاد
الروسي ويهدد القدرات العسكريه الروسيه
يهدد مصالح روسيا بشكل عام همم باعتبار ان
المرحله السابقه التي كان يدور الحديث
فيها عن امكانيه التفاهم مع بعض الاطراف
الاوروبيه قد انتهى
ولكن في نفس الوقت على الجانب الاخر
ونتحدث عن اغالبيه ال- ال- الخبراء وربما
ايضا المجموعات السياسيه في الاوساط
السياسيه الروسيه التي ترى ان هذه
العمليات العسكريه ضروره هي تعتقد بانوسكو
القادر على تحقيق انتصارات باعتبار ان حتى
هذه المساعدات العسكريه بحسب هذه
المجموعات بالتاكيد ان حتى هذه المساعدات
العسكريه همم لا تشكل نقل نوعيه في
التسليح القوات الاوكرانيه وانه سواء
الدبابات الامريكيه همم لها مثيل في الجيش
الروسي وهي 90 او همم امكانيات القوات
الجويه على قصر هذه الشحنات همم فورا
وصولها الى الاراضي اوكرانيه وبالتالي
تجريد القوات الاوكرانيه من هذه همم
القدره او القوه العسكريه التي تمنعها
الولايات المتحده ويمنحها حلف النيه لقوات
الاوكرانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه توضيح